para botar lá eu peço desculpa por
trazer acabamos como o escritor todos
culpados
nós sabemos que o governo não quer dizer
que vamos falar a começa que com com
esta situação
vós sois o sal da terra e se o saldo for
insípido confiados a olhar pra nada mais
presta
senão para lançar fora e ser pisado
pelos homens
mateus 5 3 no evangelho segundo são
mateus no capítulo 5 logo a seguir as
bem aventuranças no sermão da montanha
cristo um dos seus discípulos que os
devem serão o sal da terra devem fazer
pela terra o que o sal faz com os
alimentos e que é de induzir a sua
corrupção
o padre antónio vieira 17 séculos mais
tarde recupera esta é este motivo diz
que o pregadora deve ser a o sal da
terra
pois é não nos custa muito imaginara que
hoje em dia estas talks estas
comunicações são uma espécie de
pregações dos nossos dias sermões dos
nossos dias e pedindo que imaginar como
seria até toca do padre antónio vieira
outro cristo porque não há 20 séculos
era essa a principal função do sal que
era impedir que comidas compensa
estragas combatendo os microorganismos e
as bactérias
hoje nós usamos o sal sobretudo para
temperar a para dar sabor à e usamos
esse verbo temporara mas o verbo
temporária tem ainda um outro
significavam e que é o dar tempo para
quando aplicado aos metais quer dizer a
dar lhes uma resistência à justiça
através de um processo que é tempo para
a queda mergulhá los num líquido frio
essa festa é um evento súbito vai dar
tempo para a existência ao aos metais
daí o aço temperado
esta minha pregação é uma história de
sal e do tempo pra só não promete fazer
milagre
até 3 de janeiro de 2005 e outros aí a
em genebra na suíça para ir trabalhar no
cerne do que joão já que hoje falou
assim eu fui um dos responsáveis
problemas é outra história e o serna é
como devem saber uma hora laboratórios
partículas físicas partículas do mundo e
é também um dos locais da superfície
teste com maior número de nerds por
metro quadrado no caso alguns milhares
mais um que era eu
acaba de chegar a imaginarium mal da
área habitada apenas por sheldon anos do
do big bang theory ficam como a idéia do
que é o serra
seu eu fui morar sozinho em um
apartamento pequeno e ficava na casa de
um de um casal lá francês e era um
comportamento muito estranho particular
a tinha casas de banho e cozinha na
mesma divisão é verídico santa
inicialmente não tinha internet não
tinha o visão não tenha carro nem amigos
e quase não falava francês hu sabia que
estava a falar francês pela janela e vi
uma paisagem completamente branca de
neve neblina neve neblina neve e neblina
não leve nenhum cenário mais fácil para
encontrar o uol e do que o claro quando
eu cheguei branco era bastante
fascinantes do sul para o meridional
chinesa dura 3 disso logo a seguir à
falta qualquer coisa falta cor falta
volta falta tudo isso é minha primeira
noite foi difícil am em longe de tudo
como fazia falta dos meus amigos da
família da namorada do mar a do bacalhau
à zé do pipo
ram e eu não tenho nada que enfim com
suazo não conhecia ninguém eu lembro que
tinha vários livros em francês e
aprendendo e tentei ler mas não não
durou muito tempo esse primeiro ensaio é
mas eu tinha louvavam também um caderno
e uma caneta e forma instintiva sem
saber muito bem porque comecei a
escrever e como sair e nunca mais parei
durando nessas primeiras semanas quando
durante o dia trabalhava nos
laboratórios com circuitos eletrônicos
trabalhava com detectores de radiação
alguns semelhantes o cuco joão mostrou
anteriormente trabalhava o microscópio
saltando de um laboratório para o outro
ea noite trabalhava com as idéias com as
memórias com sentimentos alguns que nem
sabia que tinha e foi nessas matérias
perigosas e voar que eu comecei a fazer
histórias poemas cartas mas quem vian e
outras ficaram previam foi por esses
dias que eu percebi que a única forma de
valorizar com estes sentimentos tão tão
forte tão difíceis isto que me
atormentava que me fazia mal como a
solidão como ausência como angústia até
a única forma de lidar com elza
transformá-los em alguma outra coisa no
caso foram em palavras em personagens
que incorporará por essas angústias e
depois era lá problema das personagens
já não era meu
esses dias frios na suíça em que eu
acordava às seis da manhã e encaminhar
alguns quilômetros pela noiva chegará à
paragem do autocarro
esses dias foram de algum modo a minha
tempo para o tal arrefecimento brusca do
corpo e do ânimo
mas que fizeram mais resistência e mais
do que a existência obrigaram me
encontrará uma solução e um caminho e no
caso é que nem foi escrita
o meu pai que teve acesso a trechos de
pedir a forma que o governo começou a
aumentar a esperança de vida a todos os
portugueses não é o meu pai tem uma
horta que cuida de alinhamento e um
display como que os limoeiros são
caprichosos e que quando se transplantou
em maio quando se planta no novo terreno
e inicialmente recusam as alemães a
menos que sejam castigados perguntar lhe
o que era isso e eu sei como é que o
castigo consiste em bater diz com com
várias no tronco ou em pendurar os
pedras valas no tronco para os por
estresse obrigados a responder e tarô
irmãs e mesmo não sendo meu pai muito
das figuras de estilo ela ofereceu uma
grande metáfora e esta ideia do castigo
é necessária porque alguma coisa se
produza sejam limões sejam livros sejam
tese de doutoramento
este incômodo vai obrigar a uma resposta
foi algo que eu vou dar esta sair dando
uma árvore que precisa que lembrem que
tem que dar fruto
em portugal a portugal em 2010 vim aqui
para para a universidade de aveiro
enriquecer com os frutos que eu
entretanto produzir uma tese de
doutoramento feita na universidade de
florença muitas amizades que ainda hoje
mantenho e um livro começava a treinar
depois já que nos primeiros meses
ganhava irão e é o no meu país não cabem
passa o meu primeiro livro e este livro
fala de três homens três homens
complicado ter mais complexos que são o
fernando pessoa o jorge luis borges eo
franz kafka
é eu falo todos os escritores como sabem
que eu falo o imagina até dificuldades
que estiveram ao longo da visa e como
esse processo começa às dificuldades
obrigaram a escrever há tanto ver aqui o
padrão não é sair já eu não só conseguia
criar personagens para que eu pudesse
onde pudessem entregar as minhas
angústias mas criei personagens que por
elas também escreve e também passa os
ângulos produtos não é uma espécie de
passagem estão muitas angústias até ela
se afastar em nós e não nos incomodar
entanto depois escrevi o meu segundo
livro o debaixo de álbum são foi o livro
que ganhou prêmio laya eo resto é
história
são histórias muitas histórias tantas
que eu resolvi fazer um livro de contos
um livro com 54 pontos
chama se eu fosse chão é o meu terceiro
livro que podem e devem comprar que
estava instalada fora é e descobri que o
facto é estudar literatura se calhar era
mesmo o meu caminho recuperando um pouco
o estilo do do padre antónio vieira
eu acho que nós somos todos capazes de
dar alemães ou maçãs ou livros ou até
maiores descobertas científicas e aqui
convém lembrar que massa não tivesse
caído na cabeça de um certo senhor
inglês chamado newton
nós não sabemos para onde ir nós temos
árvores mas somos muitas vezes
preguiçosas e muitas vezes precisamos de
um castigo
vamos ver talvez a vida seja mais do que
a feira é mais uma questão de usar do
que receberam e que nada não chega
se não nos entregarmos isso não é
estarmos eu não tenho confessa não têm
grande queda
para amparar discursos motivadores para
que saiamos daqui todos a cantar e não é
muito homogêneo da linha do oeste
desconfio demasiado anda da natureza
humana para estar a acicatar os ânimos
mas acredito na partilha e na
transmissão do conhecimento e de
experiências e foi assim que tanto a
nossa como tantas outras espécies
sobreviveram transmitido de geração em
geração o que de bom e vai acontecer o
que de mal aconteceu e por isso eu vou
terminar simplesmente com esta exortação
agora voltando a um estilo mais de seu
irmão e que se ao longo das vossas vidas
encontrarem momentos da de impasse de
ficou lá de ambos têm o mesmo mesmo de
desespero e todos nós o encontramos
ou vamos encontrar porque a vida é é
feita também ou muitas vezes dessas
coisas mas quando tiverem nascimento
tenta transformar isso numa outra coisa
qualquer
podem ser a palavras pode ser música
pode ser vingança pode ser a trabalho
científico e vão ver o que nesse
processo vai transformaram o sofredor na
coisa surpresa e todas as coisas que
valem a pena
um bom trabalho e são sofridas não é
tudo aquilo que nos orgulhamos
verdadeiramente da visa do trabalho e
foram coisas fridas feminino repetindo o
início não se esqueçam de que vós sois o
sal da terra e assim escala pregadora
obrigado